thank you
welcome to the recent stream I'm Zach
Weissmuller joined by my co-host Liz
Wolfe and it is back to school season
and for some parts of the country that
means dealing with covid policy once
again
we're no longer in a world of indefinite
school closures and ubiquitous masking
but intermittent school closures
temporary mask mandates and covid
vaccine requirements persist
will it ever end or are we in the new
abnormal as today's guest argued in a
book with that title the author of that
book is Aaron cariati a psychiatrist and
fellow and director of the program in
bioethics and American democracy at the
ethics and public policy Center he
formerly worked at the University of
California Irvine for almost 15 years
both as a professor and director of
uci's Health Medical Ethics program
until he was fired for challenging the
school's coveted vaccine mandate a case
that we'll discuss at length with him
today Aaron cariati thank you for
talking to us thanks Zach great to be
with you and Liz
yeah we're super excited to chat with
you
for sure absolutely and we're going to
start by surveying the landscape of
covet interventions that have returned
to both K-12 schools and colleges but
first before we do that Aaron let me ask
you why do you think schools are
seemingly the last strongholds of covet
interventionism in America yeah it's a
really interesting question I talk in
the book about the fact that
higher education colleges and
universities were the first institutions
in the U.S to mandate coveted vaccines
so vaccine mandates began at
universities
and some of the earliest
institutions to adopt
the most sort of rigorous ongoing
asymptomatic testing were schools from
kindergarten on up and as you've pointed
out the masks and the vaccine mandates
and other
authoritarian I would argue coveted
measures have continued long after any
plausible Public Health justification
has has disappeared and they've
continued mostly in our institutions of
Education
and I think one of the reasons for that
is that people who want to exercise a
micromanage level of control over other
people's lives and uh try to influence
Society tend to focus on schools
obviously there are many people of Good
Will in education who care about
educating children but I think there's
also a certain
personality type perhaps people
attracted to certain
ideologies that tend to think that if we
can get them when they're really young
will influence all of society by making
these sorts of changes in the schools
that's one factor in fact
universities were sort of incubators of
a lot of the most stringent what I call
biosecurity protocols Protocols of mass
surveillance and monitoring and constant
asymptomatic testing
and really a micromanaged level of of
detailed control that I describe in
chapter one of the book I think at the
K-12 level also we we're seeing the the
influence of teachers unions and the
outsize influence of probably a small
subset of teachers that are actually
still worried about covid that don't
understand that uh the epidemiology that
shows clearly
that while adults pass covet onto
children it's very rare for children to
pass coven onto adults that the whole
Specter of asymptomatic spread was not a
driver of the pandemic and
also that we're at the point now where
most of the population has natural
immunity from a prior infection which is
very robust and or vaccine immunity and
covet is going to be around forever it's
endemic it's never going away even if we
it's not possible to do this but even if
theoretically we could eradicate it in
the human population it circulates in at
least a dozen animal species which means
the virus is going to mutate in animal
species and book you know come back and
reinfect human beings so it's never
going away it's like the annual
influenza season and this is not
something that
we need to continue living in fear of
because viruses tend to evolve in
directions of becoming more infectious
but less deadly less fatal
um and the the people who probably are
going to have really bad outcomes from
covid the Aged and the medically frail
and infirm have already been through
several waves where they were likely
exposed to the virus and
so it's it's hard from a purely
epidemiological standpoint to understand
how the schools could continue doing
things like this particularly when we
know that these interventions aren't
effective anyway at slowing or stopping
the spread of the virus I mean the
Cochrane review the gold standard of
evidence-based medicine reviewing all
the literature on masks came to the
conclusion that masks had no effect on
community spread for covet which should
not have surprised us because masks have
no effect on other respiratory viruses
as well in the community this was there
was a lot there was a large body of
research showing that for similar
respiratory viruses like influenza Mass
masking and certainly mask mandates did
not help
this is an aerosolized virus and and
your typical surgical mass or cloth mask
that people wear
um is completely
um absurd actually and and yet we're
still seeing institutions like schools
requiring people to wear this even in
the face of known harms especially for
the speech and language development
can you spell that out for us a little
bit I mean we'll definitely get into
this a little bit more later but so
would it be correct to say that there's
basically no use for masking at all or
are there specific types of scenarios
and specific types of masks where you do
sort of still support it or see it as
valid yeah I would say that there is no
use for masks at all
um including n95s for this virus and
um starting with the the masks that most
people wear the surgical or the cloth
mask there was a there was a time when
we thought that covid was spread through
Dry droplets that's that was the basis
of the six feet rule right is basically
as far as the droplets when you sneeze
or when you where you cough go but we
now know and we knew within a few months
of the pandemic
that it spread through aerosolized
mechanisms meaning your your exposure to
covet is based on how many in
symptomatically infected people are in
the room with you the size of the room
and the quality of the ventilation in
the room
um anyone who wears a mask and wears
glasses knows that the glasses fog up
right which makes it obvious that it's
not going to stop the circulation of air
into your nose and mouth but that's
exactly how the virus
spread so you know rather than putting
up plastic barriers which on the impeded
ventilation we should have been having
kids sit outside more we should have
been opening Windows we should have been
you know which in some cases we did
improve the ventilation systems on
airplanes and and in buildings but the
masking has no effect
even in highly controlled settings even
even with the use of n95s their utility
is very limited because you can't wear
an n95
for very long before the rebreathing of
your own CO2
becomes really problematic for your
health so after an hour or two of
wearing one of those masks every day you
get to the point where the harms to your
health clearly outweigh any slightly
marginal benefits benefits so looking at
the research literature even on n95s the
Cochrane review concluded that they had
little to no utility outside of very
limited highly controlled hospital
setting I recall going out to dinner and
yeah I recall going out to dinner in New
York uh early in the pandemic and you
know dining Outdoors but seeing these
massive plastic barriers uh that were
between diners and there's a certain
sense of like aren't you telling on
yourselves you clearly misunderstand
what an aerosolized virus actually like
how it functions if you think that these
plastic bearers with their little gaps
below and above are somehow going to be
the thing that prevents us from the
terrible contagion
um
it's sort of theatrical it was a kind of
demonstration that we're trying really
really really hard to keep everyone safe
no matter how absurd the things we're
doing actually are
let me bring up that Cochrane review
article that you've referenced a couple
of times so we can just clearly State
what it says this is a meta-analysis of
a bunch of different randomized control
studies
um and the objective that I've
highlighted here is to assess the
effectiveness of physical interventions
to interrupt to reduce the spread of
acute respiratory viruses so they looked
at masking distancing hand washing and
their conclusion as you stated is that
well their conclusion is that there's
uncertainty about the effects of face
masks and that the pooled results of the
randomized control trials did not show a
clear reduction in respiratory viral
infection with the use of medical slash
surgical masks furthermore there were no
clear differences between the use of
surgical masks compared with n95s in
healthcare workers when used in routine
care to reduce respiratory viral
infections they found hand hygiene was
likely to modestly reduce the burden of
respiratory illnesses and to your point
harms associated with physical
interventions were under investigated
and they conclude there's need for a
large well-designed there there's need
for more large well-designed randomized
controlled trials addressing the
effectiveness of many of these
interventions in multiple settings so at
the very least it's a big question mark
of this needs a lot more study it it
kind of is like the closest you'll get
to like masks don't really work
according to any evidence that we've
been able to turn up
though yeah I
there which they tweaked under pressure
from mask Fanatics are a little bit
underdetermined if you read actually the
results of
um of the overall review I think the
conclusion should have been stated a
little more strongly without the kind of
we're not sure yet we don't know
question mark prior to covert there were
15 randomized controlled Trials of masks
and Community settings for Respiratory
viruses all 15 of them were negative
showing no benefit so yes we can always
do more randomized controlled trials but
I think this I you know I think they
actually Paul Thacker and other uh
investigative journalists have written
on this recently uh what happened after
they initially published the review was
they came under pressure basically from
advocacy groups and ended up tweaking
some of that language that you just
um read from to make the conclusion
sound a little bit more agnostic and
like we need further research and I I
think actually their their entire review
read as a whole does not
uh support the soft pedaling of of that
kind of you know agnostic we're not sure
yet attitude why do you think there is
that kind of pressure to not acknowledge
the weak evidence of this intervention
it seems like there would be a desire to
learn from this and do something
different next time
but I mean unfortunately we have a
ruling class who
will never ever ever admit that they
were wrong about something so there are
a lot of reputations at stake from
public health officials from political
leaders from institutional leaders who
pushed Mass mandates on the public uh
who are going to have a difficult time I
think just simply saying look we tried
this maybe we were acting in good faith
maybe we were just ignorant of the data
whatever okay
um you know but it turns out that this
didn't work and so let's learn from that
and move on I think that I think the
American people would accept that and
and
um you know be forgiving about some of
those mistakes if they were honestly
acknowledged and they even have an out
now they can say well in the face of new
evidence we're going to stop using masks
but I think it's just too many people
feel that their reputation is staked on
these kinds of interventions and also
too many people have been become
conditioned into the psychological
feeling that this protects me that this
is some way for me to deal with my
free-floating anxiety and they haven't
been able to come out of that
sort of conditioned response state where
the mask has become a kind of magical
Talisman that makes me feel a little
more safe regardless of whether it's
actually doing anything
one person who's been pushing back
against this mask study is Anthony fauci
and we have a clip of him doing just
that uh just last week we're going to
play that and then I'd like to get your
reaction to What fauci's saying here
let's roll that clip hunt you know John
if you some of the studies the confusing
the study that recently has been now
quoted a lot and causing a lot of
confusion is this Cochrane study which
even the people who run the Cochran
studies say that that study can be
misleading because people have commented
on that study saying absolutely Mass
don't work which is absolutely not the
case because there are a number of
studies that show that mass actually do
work and there's a lot of confusion when
you take a broad a series of studies and
you look at them in a meta-analysis only
a couple of those studies were
specifically looking at covid so I think
we better be careful that that study
that that people keep talking about can
be very very misleading there's a lot of
good data that masks work but you've
also said we're not going to go back to
the time of Federal Mass mandates that's
that's the thing of the past no I don't
see that in the future at all I mean I
can see that if we get a significant
uptick in cases that you may see the
recommendation that must be used under
certain circumstances and indoor crowded
settings but I don't see there'd be
certainly not federal mandates I would
be extremely surprised if we would see
that there may be local organizations
that may require Mass but I think what
we're going to see mostly if the cases
go up that there might be
recommendations not mandates there's a
big difference there specifically I
believe the study he's citing is a big
one that in Bangladesh where they handed
out what masks to one Village and not to
another Village and there was a
reduction in transmission of the disease
so what's your response to what Dr fauci
had to say about the Cochrane review
meta-analysis so the mask Fanatics
always point to that same Bangladesh
study
which had so many confounders so many
other factors that could have accounted
for the differences in covert raids
between those two re regions I I believe
that study was sloppy it had methodology
that was
poor
um and that one study needs to be read
again in the context of the research
literature as a whole it's not enough to
say you well we have 15 negative trials
and one apparently positive trial then
you have to scratch your head and say
okay why did this trial come to a
different conclusion do we need to
scrutinize this study and
look at the methodology and see why it's
not squaring up with what the other
research is showing it's never the case
that one scientific study is sufficient
to answer a complex question like
what effect do masks have on this
particular respiratory virus
so
you've always got to pay place the
research literature in the context of
all the rest of the research not just
the research that happened during the
pandemic for covid but also analogous
research that happened prior to the
pandemic for other respiratory viruses
and then I think when you do that it
becomes very clear that this is not an
effective intervention there's no
plausible mechanism of action in other
words if you if you just look at things
from a physics perspective you know how
big is the virus how big are the holes
in these masks
um is the virus spread by droplets or is
it aerosolized is it is it basically in
the air as a kind of gaseous spread
um and when you look at it from all
those different angles not only do the
studies show at a clinical level overall
the the
strong preponderance of research
uh that mass don't work
but also we have no
basis in physics to believe that the
masks could in theory work and so I
think fauci is really grasping at straws
it's a little bit of an embarrassment
actually to the scientific Community I
heard him on another interview basically
say wow the Cochrane review found that
masks don't work on a population level
but maybe they still work on an
individual level
I'm not sure how to interpret or what to
make of that distinction
um but it's normally we would see a
connection between those two things
right exactly if the masks worked for
individuals and you measured a bunch of
individuals you would see a population
wide correct so tell me a little bit
like post SARS in so much of Asia
masking caught on uh and so to some
degree that part of the world had a much
easier time you know sort of re-adopting
that especially in crowded public spaces
are you saying essentially that like
that's also totally uh not
maybe but like a pointless exercise a
pointless thing to do was was post SARS
masking also pointless and did we see
the same um sort of lack of effect in
that region
it is pointless
um the SARS outbreak uh fortunately was
not as widespread as a sarsko V2 as the
virus that causes covid
um so again masks may have given people
some psychological sense that they were
doing something and made them feel safer
but a subjective feeling that this is
doing something for me is not actually
evidence of efficacy so I think we can
now put to rest including for Asian
countries the question of that this
habit of masking when it comes to flu
season or when there are outbreaks of
things like SARS
um the I mentioned the the
Specter of asymptomatic spread earlier
which we had evidence very early on in
the pandemic uh that asymptomatic spread
was not a driver of disease but
basically uh and once we had clear
evidence that that was the case that
evidence was not really shared with the
public it wasn't widely known people
still thought I could be walking down
the street and see someone who looks
perfectly healthy they don't have any
symptoms and I might get coveted from
them and this basically turned every
other person into a Potential Threat to
my existence
that's a terrible State of Mind to put
people in particularly unnecessarily
when the science didn't support a notion
like that
that creates all kinds of free-floating
anxiety that people want to feel that I
I have some kind of power or control
over right there's maybe maybe if I put
on my mask and you put on your mask and
we do this thing and we do it well
uh that can lower the risk somewhat so
I'm taking back some sense of agency and
control rather than just having this
constant threat hanging about me and
about every other person I meet like a
sort of cloud and in fact fauci sort of
hinted
early on in the pandemic
that yeah well we sort of know because
you might remember early on he said that
there was no evidence in favor of masks
and he was right about that and then he
changed his mind for reasons that are
still unclear when we asked him under
deposition why he changed his mind about
masking between a Friday and a Monday he
couldn't recall any of the studies that
he relied on when he changed his mind
but he was he was pretty sure the
evidence was was good
um but at one point when he was still
saying Mass don't work he sort of hinted
but yeah maybe we ought to give people
this as a way of kind of giving them
some sense of control maybe there's some
sort of psychological benefit to wearing
a mask
um but the problem with that theory even
at a psychological level I'm going to
put on my psychiatrist hat for a moment
is that it actually just creates a
conditioned response that confirms that
I'm in constant Danger from other people
right otherwise I wouldn't be putting on
the mask when I'm whenever I'm around
someone or even when I'm driving in my
car or riding a bicycle alone so this
basically creates a conditioned response
to confirm that other people are a
threat to me or that I'm under this sort
of constant threat when I encounter you
know my fellow fellow human being and in
the end that actually increases fear and
anxiety rather than diminishing it
I want to take us back through some of
the concrete examples of the lingering
covet interventions in schools because
we don't we shouldn't we're not giving
the impression or implying that you know
we're we're back in 2020 or something
like this but what we're seeing are
things like this ABC news story school
districts in Kentucky and Texas cancel
classes amid surge of illnesses
including covid so this is a case of
lots of kids I guess testing positive
for covid and other illnesses and they
go below some sort of attendance
threshold and just say we're going to go
remote for this week uh there's also
this if I could just intervene I want to
I want to correct that headline
because a positive test for covid is not
in fact an illness
a school might have a policy that if you
test positive for covid and by the way
we're going to test the students
routinely even when they're not
symptomatic if you test positive for
covet you have to stay home
but that doesn't mean that the student
who is staying home has an illness right
and illness is defined by clinical
symptoms that impair a person's
functioning in some way an illness is
not defined by the results of of a test
and you know without getting down into
the Weeds on the problem with the PCR
testing and the high cycle thresholds
that basically result in many false
positive tests and so on and so forth
a positive test for covet even if it's a
valid test that detects basically some
fragment of the virus in your body does
not mean that you have an illness and I
think it's important to emphasize that
it does not mean that you have something
that you can actually spread to other
people
either so this would be an example of
like the the new abnormal lingering
because exactly or you wouldn't send
your you wouldn't test your kid for a
virus you would just observe if they are
sick or not and then so that that might
be
you know that might be boosting up the
number of absences because they're we
don't we can't really know uh but you it
it's probably the case that there's some
percentage of those kids who just tested
positive or who otherwise would have
gone to school and yeah suppose suppose
that you have a test with a two percent
false positive rate
well if you repeat that test
indiscriminately on the entire student
body
twice a week you're going to get a lot
of sick people with covet
that don't even have don't even have any
virus much less symptomatic illness so
this is a basic principle that was
drummed into our head in medical school
that we threw out during the pandemic
and that's that you do not use
diagnostic tests indiscriminately on
healthy people because that tends to
create more problems than it solves this
problem of false positives which then
causes anxiety and requires you to work
do more diagnostic workups sometimes
even invasive procedures biopsies and so
forth that have risks associated with
them uh but also basically if if I were
to run a battery of tests on all three
of us right now I were to do a CT scan
of our entire body
and I were to do a whole array of lab
tests looking for problems
those tests would come up with something
that's probably an outlier that's
probably a nothing Burger that's there's
going to be some blip on the CT scan
there's a blip in your lung and it's
it's a benign calcification
but you know now that you've seen it on
the CT scan it it's like okay well is
that something to worry about is that
cancerous or is that should and that you
know you get to the point where I want
to resolve this so I'm going to get a
lung biopsy which has serious risks
associated with you know sticking a
needle in there to aspirate this thing
or whatever so
indiscriminate especially repeated uh
testing of healthy people is bad Medical
Practice uh you don't just test test
test you test when you have reason to
look for something I encountered this a
little bit not personally but some moms
who gave birth around the same time as
me also in Manhattan I gave birth to my
son uh in Manhattan uh last year in
October and RSV was going around New
York covid was going around I mean it
was fall There Was You know the classic
surge that many school districts
experience but a few moms have told me
this absolutely terrifying story of and
I got coveted tested but it came back
negative and you know then that's part
of hospital admission nowadays uh even
for mothers who are giving birth I know
some moms though who got tested and
without any symptoms it came back
positive and then what this did
essentially is it triggers a whole bunch
of regulations that go into effect that
make it so that uh you know for in in
most settings the the mother has to be
masked can you imagine being masked
while trying to be you know in labor for
many many hours in many situations it
means visitors are restricted and
they're just unable to actually have
family members present next to them
um I think that for whatever reason we
downplay the severe human cost
um that many people have encountered
um as a result of this and it's really
horrifying to me to think like what if I
had tested positive what if in that
situation you know my mom and my husband
and people who are totally fine with
getting sick
um you know while being in my vicinity
what would have happened if they hadn't
been allowed to be there with me um
during one of the hardest times in my
life and in my son's life I mean there's
a really horrifying thing when you think
about okay what is the actual cost
Beyond just the financial cost Beyond
just the cost in terms of time to the
doctor or nurse I mean I think there's a
real human cost there that people for
whatever reason are not comfortable
confronting yeah very well said very
well said that's a perfect perfect
example of the harms of testing testing
seems like a benign thing but it's it's
not um and it's always a ton of mischief
and it's always the more vulnerable
groups right it's K-12 school children
and sometimes college students uh people
in medical uh environments mothers
children like young children in daycare
settings uh it's groups that necessarily
have to interface with things you have
to interface with the medical system you
have to interface with the school system
if you're going through a certain
situation or if you're of a certain age
and there's really not much of a choice
to opt out I wish I had had the ability
to shop for hospitals and care providers
who did not require me to mask but you
know what in Brooklyn and Manhattan in
you know 2022 it was really really hard
to find people that were actually sort
of in accordance with my values in that
regard
um Zach did you want to take us to yeah
well I was going to ask Aaron is that
sort of what you mean by you know the
subtitle of your book which I'll throw
up here is the rise of the biomedical
Security State which is quite a catchy
phrase and I think I've heard uh some
politicians down in Florida use it but
is that kind of what you mean by that
this idea that if we overdo it on the
testings on the testing and on the
metrics that now we're stuck in this
world where
where were our movements and our our
freedoms are sort of bound up by the
whether or not we have a false positive
on some sort of biometric test yeah
exactly and even even going beyond the
kinds of things that we've described
um I talk about in the book sort of the
three elements of what I call the
biomedical Security State the first is
an increasingly militarized Public
Health apparatus
um and I can get down into the weeds a
little bit on what that means if you're
interested the second element is the use
of digital Technologies of surveillance
and control so the simplest example of
that is the vaccine passport having to
show a QR code to get on a train get on
a plane go to a restaurant gather at
public space demonstrating that in the
United States as well there was a third
time where in order to literally enter
the country of which one is a citizen
you have to prove that you are that you
medically qualify exactly exactly
um you you know this would have sounded
insane to us in 2018 but after
a year of prolonged lockdowns and school
closures in the kind of psychological
and emotional abuse of those policies I
think people were willing to do just
about anything to get their freedoms
back freedoms which never should have
been taken away from them in the first
place I argue in the book
um but there are other forms of digital
surveillance that we saw during the
pandemic as well so the CDC bought from
a very shady company bulk cell phone
data to monitor basically people's
movements and how how many people were
gathering at churches and schools and
other public institutions to monitor
basically compliance with lockdown
orders they admitted when this Vice
broke the story on this they admitted
that they were going to continue doing
this through 2026 and they talked about
all kinds of other public health
applications the data was supposedly
anonymized but there were some
researchers at Princeton showing that
with only four data points you know for
each of the numbers they could easily
identify who that phone belonged to so
it was not anonymized uh in any
meaningful way
and this was done without the con
certainly without the consent of the
American people but without even the
knowledge of the American people so this
level of kind of intrusive surveillance
that's happening in the background that
we don't even realize right okay I
didn't opt in on my phone for the
contact racing or tell me if someone
around me is tested positive for covet
because I don't I don't want to be
monitored or surveilled in that way and
yet the government was doing it anyway
without my consent
and those two elements the the
increasingly militarized Public Health
apparatus and the digital Technologies
of surveillance and control are backed
up by the police powers of the state so
you could think of the example of the
Canadian truckers protest in Ottawa
uh Justin Trudeau invokes the emergency
act for the first time in Canadian
history
um and to sent in a militarized police
force to rough up the truckers and
forcibly remove them from the city even
though there was there were no incidents
of violence at the protests uh prior to
the police going in and basically
roughing up the truckers
and uh and beyond that
he basically commandeered the banks who
cooperated to freeze the bank accounts
of not only of the truckers but of
anyone who gave money to the freedom
Convoy
so you know imagine giving a 50 donation
to this protest and one day and going to
the ATM neck the next day and you can't
withdraw money from your checking
account because
the banks have Frozen it under the
directives of the government
um this this is a pretty severe form of
social control
that
um the declared state of emergency
um empowered
Executives particularly Governors
presidents Prime Ministers to exercise a
level of direct control over populations
that they in the past they were never
able to exercise
the declared state of emergency at the
federal level
which went on for the better part of
three years
gives the president of the United States
128 additional extra Constitutional
Powers that he wouldn't otherwise have
he's the one who declares the state of
emergency he's the one who unilaterally
decides when the emergency is over with
no checks and balances on that system
and he's the one who accrues the
additional Powers including access to
emergency funding which is a big deal
because Congress typically holds the
purse strings right the president wants
a new program he's got to go hat in hand
to get Congress to appropriate some
funds but under the state of emergency
he's got a lot more money at his
disposal uh yeah so and
go ahead sorry so yeah I mean that's
that's a very quick kind of um quick
summary of the kinds of things that I
have in mind when I talk about
biosecurity
yeah and I I want to explore
particularly near the end of this
conversation where you think that might
be going and ways to stop the advance
towards that let's linger a little bit
on some of the concrete
um present day examples just to see what
is actually going on in some of these
schools we already mentioned the the uh
you know the absences this is an
elementary school in Maryland
where they imposed uh KN 95 masks on all
students and staff for the next 10 days
except while eating or drinking
um and this is I mean we've already
talked about the kind of weakening case
on the science of masks this is putting
a the most one of the most kind of
severe types of face coverings over an
elementary school student all day and
I had the chance when I covered this
issue in Florida when I covered the mask
Wars I asked the head of the Florida
chapter of American Association of
Pediatrics like you know what what are
the psychological effects of this
because it just seems from a common
sense perspective that a a kid not being
able to see other kids might have some
sort of effect and she was like well you
know kids are resilient and we know that
uh you know covet can spread if you
don't put on the mask and the thing that
struck me about that was
that they're willing to accept the
uncertainty of evidence around masking
since we know we don't have a robust
body of evidence there but they're
willing to kind of roll the dice on the
social psychological side of things does
as someone who works in mental health
does that surprise you that that sort of
message was coming out from yes an
organization like the American
Association of Pediatrics it's shocking
and very Discerning Academy of
Pediatrics yeah
um I mean that the policy that you just
described with the n95s for kids this is
a form of child abuse
in my opinion I I I mean that very
literally this is clearly going to be
harmful
um all masks are harmful to children in
especially in the early years with
speech and language development uh any
child that has any hearing impairment or
difficulty hearing needs to see the face
in order to supplement their ability to
uh to communicate and to listen
um I mean set aside scientific research
on this just use your common sense what
do you suppose it's like for a child to
go through an entire week of school and
not see a single person smile at him or
her
I mean that's that's terrible
that's just wrong
n95s also are going to cause pulmonary
problems for those children there there
was one study that showed that if you do
get coveted
and you're masking well you have covered
uh you tend to get worse illness because
it rebreathing of the viral particles
caused them to go down deeper into the
lungs where you get the sort of covet
pneumonia type Pro problems that tend to
produce more severe symptoms so there's
plenty of evidence on the harms of masks
it's not a question mark
we we have the evidence rolling in talk
to any speech and language pathologist
they'll talk about that the wave of
children
um that are coming in look at the
cognitive development look at the
academic achievement of children
um in these circumstances there's plenty
of evidence that this policy is going to
do damage we don't have to be agnostic
about that and you know it's worth
reminding people as well that healthy
children are not harmed by covet
are these temporary setbacks in terms of
language acquisition and other parts of
childhood development like do we have
any evidence to indicate oh there's a
six-month delay versus oh this is a
longer term more permanent thing I guess
what's still pretty early but do you
have a sense yeah my sense is uh and
this is based on a lot of research on
development and neurobiology there are
critical periods of development where if
certain things don't happen
with a lot of work you can do some catch
up later but you're never going to
achieve the level of development that
you would have had it been done during
the critical period so fancy term the
brain has what's called neuroplasticity
that's the ability to change with
experience
but and that continues throughout the
lifespan which is great
but there are also critical periods of
neuroplastic plasticity where the brain
is more plastic more open to change and
development language development is a
perfect example of that if you learn a
second language before the age of six or
seven usually it's much easier to learn
first of all and you can speak it
fluently without an accent you learn
after uh seven eight years old it takes
longer to acquire the language anyone
who's taken foreign language classes in
college understands you got to work
really really hard
um and it's almost impossible to acquire
that second language without speaking it
you know with an accent you don't speak
with a facility of a native speaker
so that's a great example of yeah there
are critical periods of development
where a lot of work later can help you
catch up somewhat but it's not going to
get you to the point where you would
have been had you not missed that
critical period and that's why
just saying children are resilient I
mean okay children are resilient but
that's no reason to abuse them
fair enough let's move let's move
forward through that we we covered a
little bit of K to 12. this is also as
you mentioned at the top you know higher
education is really where some of the
very first vaccine mandates were imposed
and they are still being imposed in some
universities uh the University of
Michigan as our uh colleague Robbie
Suave reported reported here will force
students with covid to leave campus they
have an isolation policy that if you
test positive for covid-19 you have to
make an isolation plan leave your
residence hall even if you're in a
single room and then make uh you know
pay for your own accommodations off
campus I dug into like what like how
widespread is this policy this is from
the American college Health Association
and this one that I have highlighted
here uh 8.8 percent of call of colleges
surveyed had that policy where you okay
to relocate at your own expense uh it's
almost 50 percent have some sort of
isolation policy and then this uh twelve
and eight percent the eight percent is
offers no direction for students who
have covid-19 and then 12 percent
um says that they uh will be asked to
isolate in place and their roommates are
offered free alternative housing if if
they want if they're at high risk of
getting very sick those that that 20
category strikes me as the most rational
uh but uh there's also the question of
vaccine policies on campus
um for the fall semester vaccines are
required for all students in uh uh 7.4
percent of cases and required for
subgroups of students for example
residential students
who live on campus
that's just how it goes right like
you're interested you know eight yeah so
we're like over 18 percent basically uh
vaccine mandate for college campuses and
then you know 60 percent recommended and
then 23 have no requirement or
recommendation on coveted vaccination
for students so are these two questions
Aaron where do you fall what what do you
think should be
the covet policies for higher ed yeah so
I'm completely opposed to the vaccine
mandates
um I I sacrificed my career in academic
medicine to challenge the University of
California's vaccine mandate policy
these vaccines we knew from the very
beginning did not stop infection or
transmission of the virus therefore
whatever risks or benefits of the
vaccines there are accrued to the
individual who's accepting or declining
vaccination so that the whole argument
of get vaccinated for the sake of others
even if you're not worried even if
you're not going to benefit even if you
know you're at an age bracket that's you
know not high risk for problems with
covid that argument falls apart it
doesn't apply to these vaccines and so
we have to apply the traditional medical
ethics doctrine of informed consent
right where there's risk we can argue
about how how risky these vaccines are
but where there's any degree of risk
there must be Choice there must be the
ability to voluntarily accept those
risks for the sake of potential benefits
or to decline them so on a purely
ethical uh grounds setting aside issues
of safety and efficacy of these vaccines
vaccine mandates are unethical
um and the I mean why are you paying
tuition at a school
uh with a policy like this where again
when you're healthy
you have to isolate right now look if
you have symptomatic illness of any kind
if you have any respiratory virus and it
you know you're really sort of
symptomatic and you're coughing and
sneezing but you got a fever yeah stay
home right
um
and maybe the campus could find a way to
you know if you have roommates or
another situation that makes it more
difficult to isolate maybe they could
facilitate a way to to give you a single
room for the people who are sick or
something like that fine fine but again
let's indiscriminately test people and
then anyone who comes back with a
positive test kicked them off campus I
mean this is just insane this is totally
insane why would you pay money to go to
an institution like this I just you know
I just can't it's it's it amazes me that
people subject themselves to this kind
of treatment uh and and Fork over tons
of money for the privilege of of being
treated like that it's it's yeah crazy
you were you were an early dissenter
from the tyrannical covid regime uh I
mean you were fired from UC Irvine
because of your refusal to comply with
the vaccine mandate could you tell us
your personal story how you made that
decision I mean you stuck by your
principles at tremendous personal cost
yeah
so I was the director of the medical
Ethics program which means that I did
all the ethics consults in the hospital
directed the ethics consult service I
taught the required ethics course to
medical students
and I was actually on a committee at the
UC Office of the President which oversaw
not just my Branch campus UC Irvine but
all the UCS UCLA UCSF and we had a
committee with representation from all
five of the UC hospitals
bioethicists and critical care doctors
and we vetted basically all of the and
and wrote many of the covid policies
up until the vaccine mandate policy
which
puzzled me because it was clear to me
this was going to be the most ethically
controversial of any of the policies
that we had developed and so why hadn't
it gone through our committee it just
came down from the top came down from on
high and there was no discussion or
debate about it I tried to get a
conversation going at the Office of the
President about this policy because I
knew it was going to be publicly
controversial and I have serious
concerns about it
and was just met with radio silence so I
ended up
um in I think it was June of 21
uh
publishing an article in the Wall Street
Journal with the title University
vaccine mandates are unethical and as I
mentioned before those were the first
institutions mandating vaccines that's
why I sort of focused on universities
and I made the case that I just made to
you regarding inform informed consent
and then I passed that around to the
committee to try to stir the pot and you
know get get some discussion and again
no discussion no debate we're not
talking about this and a week or two
later the proposed policy was finalized
and then once the policy went in so if
nobody engaged with it nobody engaged
with that Wall Street Journal article
not at all
yeah which I found because these were
people that we
I was on the phone with the UC general
counsel like every night hammering out
all these other covert policies the
ventilator triage policy the vaccine
allocation policy who should get it
first when it first rolls out
um all that kind of stuff and then
suddenly nope this is uh this is not
under discussion it was just very
bizarre
and then once they instituted it I
started seeing my colleagues getting
steamrolled so I because I had written
the piece in the in the journal I was
publicly known as an opponent of the
policy I had students and faculty and
staff reaching out to me students saying
things like I'm not a religious person
so I can't in good conscience submit a
religious exemption to their credit
they're trying to be you know ethically
scrupulous
um but I have conscience-based
objections to this vaccines or I have
medical concerns about safety and
efficacy and it became virtually
impossible to get a medical exemption
even in circumstances where that might
have been appropriate in California
because the California medical board was
threatening Physicians who wrote any
exemptions basically
um so it was a really terrible situation
I was seeing students getting kicked out
I was seeing nurses that worked every
day during the pandemic and had worked
at the University Hospital
you know alongside me for 15 years uh
getting fired
and I just got to the point where it was
like okay I can be an ivory Tower
intellectual and you know I've said my
piece I've made my case it actually
hasn't had an effect or
um I can actually try to do something to
change this policy
and uh I think that the the the final
decision came down to just trying to
project ahead a few months to where I
would start teaching the
um annual ethics course to the med
students and just feeling like I
couldn't stand up with any credibility
and talk about informed consent talk
about moral courage and integrity if I
hadn't tried to do something so I made
the Fatal decision to challenge that
mandate in federal court
um and the university immediately moved
to to get rid of me
um on the pretense of alleged
non-compliance with the same policy that
I was uh challenging in federal court I
say alleged because the university also
twice denied my medical exemption that
was signed by my physician so that's
what happened to me
um did you have the opportunity to
appeal that denial of medical exemption
uh I did and they denied it again on wow
so
what was with the case the substance of
the case you were making which was that
first of all you had been infected by
covid before and so presumably had
natural immunity to the virus that as
far as we knew at the time was as good
or better
um and that's only been borne out by the
evidence since
um I want to just pull up a little bit
of your uh Wall Street Journal op-ed you
said that uh these coercive mandates
violate basic principles of medical
ethics informed consent is likewise
required is required for medical
decisions in all adults of sound mind
this is arguably the most deeply rooted
Doctrine in contemporary medical ethics
um first could you talk about informed
consent and then I have a follow-up
question about vaccine mandates as a The
Wider the broader concept of vaccine
mandates beyond the covid vaccine yeah
so informed consent in a nutshell is the
notion that adults of sound mind
have the right to accept or decline
proposed medical interventions after
receiving adequate information about the
risks benefits and alternatives to those
treatments and they have the right to
make those decisions on behalf of their
children who are too young to consent
um and even in people who are
incapacitated and can't give consent
because they're in a coma we still have
to obtain informed consent for medical
interventions from a proxy from a family
member or from someone who's been
appointed a conservator or power of
attorney
and this Doctrine goes all the way back
to the early 20th century but that one
of the landmark articulations was of
course the Nuremberg code following the
Nazi doctor trial where about a dozen a
couple of dozen uh Nazi Physicians were
tried for crimes against humanity for
basically doing gruesome experiments on
death camp prisoners without those
prisoners consent and the world
responded with horror some of those
doctors actually received the death
penalty and hung about half half dozen
of them were convicted uh
for capital crimes
and the nurburg code grew out of the
experience of the Nuremberg trials in
the very first principle articulated in
the Nuremberg code is the principle of
informed consent for medical research
which was later applied in federal law
to also requiring informed consent for
all medical interventions and even for
medical tests speaking of speaking of
testing we can't run tests on patients
in most circumstances without gaining
their informed consent
would there ever be a situation where
a vaccine mandates would not violate
medical ethics in in this kind of
emergency type of situ where there's a
panda let's say a deadlier pandemic a
more effective vaccine
um how do you how do those factors
change the calculation if at all from an
ethical Viewpoint so in my view they
don't so I I am an opponent in principle
of vaccine mandates across the board I
think prior to the pandemic
um I might have been more open to some
of these they're they're usually
theoretical hypothetical really deadly
virus everyone is at risk which already
is not a real world scenario because
really deadly viruses tend to burn out
very quickly they tend not to produce
epidemics or pandemics because they kill
people too quickly before they can
spread so viruses come in two flavors
low mortality viruses that are very
contagious and can spread across
countries or across the
so um so examples of much higher
mortality viruses that um that burn out
rather quickly uh the Ebola virus would
be a good example of that right much
more concerning infection fatality rates
than covet but only
very time limited localized outbreaks
that can be usually be contained much
more easily than something like covid
which is basically impossible to stop
it's okay so where where does something
like uh smallpox work so yeah small
smallpox would be somewhere in the
middle smallpox is probably the the
strongest example for vaccine mandates
would be smallpox it's got about a 30
mortality rate so it can produce
epidemics but not not necessarily
pandemics but it certainly can produce
Regional problems
um
the uh
the argument I think when it comes to
something like smallpox even then it
falls apart because if you have
if you have a virus that's deadly enough
and you have an intervention that is
sufficiently effective you have a
sterilizing vaccine that protects the
recipient
um you're not going to have to mandate
it to people people will voluntarily
take it if it's clearly and obviously
good for their health and those that
don't
um are not necessarily putting other
people In Harm's Way because if if if
the intervention is as effective as this
you know hypothetical scenario describes
then the people who want that protection
can have it available to them in the
form of the vaccine so there's a natural
rebuttal to that so frequently I think
about this in the context of smallpox
but also polio because actually when my
son was an infant prior to being
eligible to getting vaccinated against
polio we live right next to
um Hasidic South Williamsburg and so
this was actually kind of an interesting
thing because we had a few cases of
polio detected in New York City and
detected in Rockland County right around
the time when I had a baby in my arms
who had not yet been vaccinated against
polio what do you say in terms of the
you know what do you say to the
immunocompromise or people with really
really small infants were even if they
want to opt into that uh protection
there for whatever reason unable to do
so at that time I'm sure you've
considered this a great length yeah
absolutely
um
so I think bodily integrity and bodily
autonomy are sufficient overriding Goods
um that uh
that accepting some degree of risk in
order to maintain bodily integrity and
bodily autonomy in order to avoid abuses
of power
um is important for us as a society as
as a whole I don't think we want to live
in a society where anyone has the right
to force another person to inject
something into their body that they may
or may not want
um and you know there may be
circumstances where the time limited use
of force to quarantine contagious people
that are symptomatic might be warranted
because that's a that's a Time limited
infringe infringement on civil liberties
that may be justified for the sake of
protecting other people
um but the kind of scenario that you
describe
um we're still talking about
infinitesimally low risks of acquiring a
disease like polio in the in the current
context
um and so I just don't think that that
very small theoretical risk justifies
um forcing vaccines on the Hasidic
Jewish Community for example
yeah I also say that one you know
consequentialist argument of all this
like just have having seen it all play
out is the way that these heavy-handed
mandates were implemented which I was
against from the beginning as well is
that uh predictably people don't like it
and now they're more distrustful of
vaccines on the whole and I think that's
right that's put us in a very dangerous
situation especially given that they now
learned about all this laboratory
manipulation of viruses like who know
what's who knows what's coming and this
is unfortunately an issue like a very
real issue that we have to all think
about both on a policy level and also a
personal level like what we're going to
do if that God forbid what happened I
think to your point Zach there is this
interesting unintended consequence that
all three of us seem to be storing in
the very front of our minds but that for
whatever reason our policy makers uh
haven't really stopped to consider what
which is that you do squander public
trust and you might in fact find
yourself in a situation many years down
the road where you wish you hadn't done
that I actually think that to your point
Aaron um with the specific Hasidic
example and these relatively few polio
cases that were detected in the
Wastewater in New York City uh in New
York City and surrounding areas we did
actually see in Rockland County where
there's a really really big Hasidic
Enclave exactly what you were talking
about earlier which was a voluntary
vaccination Drive where a bunch of
Hasidic moms seeing the news about this
polio outbreak were like oh crap a bunch
of my kids aren't vaccinated and just
immediately hopped into action and went
to these local vaccine drives and very
quickly got their children vaccinated
recognizing that up until this point
polio isn't really something that
circulates in the U.S and hadn't really
been a realistic fear but now that there
are a few cases that have been detected
now they're choosing to protect their
families and no government coercion was
necessary in order to get that outcome
in fact all the government did in this
case would say this is available to you
here's the news as to the Wastewater
detection here are the news as to where
this is circulating and if you would
like to you can come to this place and
get this free vaccine available to you
and people decided to opt into that of
their own volition which I think is a
really heartening case study but that is
a beautiful real world example of
good Public Health functioning well and
and relying on the Goodwill
uh and the trust and the Civic
mindedness and the other directedness of
you know most Americans uh including
people that might you know naturally
because of cultural or religious reasons
have skepticism about the need for those
things and you know we don't have to
coerce parents to help their kids brush
their teeth right or to feed their kids
or to you know
um
take them outside once in a while so
they get sunlight because most parents
want to do the best thing for their
children and their children's health
when you start forcing things on them
going back to the discussion of masks or
you mandate a vaccine for an illness
that they're they're not at high risk
from and That vaccine has potential side
effects or adverse consequences you
squander precisely that trust in that
Civic mindedness of uh voluntary
voluntarily complying in situations in a
sort of other directed community-minded
Spirit and I think that is a per the
situation you described is a perfect
contrast to what we actually did in
covid and you see you see the different
results and you see that the different
attitudes to both of those things
fostered in the community and I think it
becomes pretty clear that
um you know we can we can come up with
hypothetical scenarios that you know
might incline us to believe yeah we
should Force this on people but if you
see how that actually plays out
historically in real world examples I
think it becomes very clear that that's
not the that's not the way to go with
Public Health
the last for the last part of this
conversation I want to take us to some
of the pushback both the pushback that's
been happening in the real world and
some of what you suggest in your book
and I think there's no better place to
start than in the Sunshine State in down
in Florida where I'm coming to you from
um and you know DeSantis uh made his
name a name for himself going the
opposite direction that the public
health establishment went in this
country and he recently was restating
that case at a press conference in
Jacksonville so let's take a look at
what DeSantis had to say and I'd like to
get your reaction to his comments
you give these people an inch they will
take a mile and so in Florida not only
did we stand in the fight when it was
happening but we've enacted permanent
protections against these policies now
and in the future for Floridians and
that is really really important and so
uh you as a parent can send your kid to
school and the school can't force them
to wear a muzzle all day they're allowed
to breathe
you also have a right as a Floridian to
earn a living regardless of whether you
want to take the latest covid-19 booster
shot or not uh they can't make you do it
in Florida
same thing we provided protections for
businesses against local governments
when local governments were doing things
back in 2020 I issued a blanket pardon
for all the fines and fees that local
governments were imposing on individuals
and businesses and I think we're the
only state that has banned gain of
function research and so we're not doing
that yet
we've also protected the rights of
Physicians to be able to treat their
patients according to their best
judgment we're not going to be like
California and having Physicians be
penalized just because they're
dissenting from the accepted narrative
we did not and we will not allow
the dystopian visions of paranoid
hypercondriacs control our health
policies
so what do you think of what DeSantis
has done and is in doing in Florida
policy wise
I've been a big fan of desantis's
approach to covid uh from the very
beginning I think you know he locked
down initially but very quickly started
looking at the data himself consulted my
colleague Jay bhattacharya and others
who gave him sound
epidemiological and public health advice
and the outcomes speak for themselves
the age-adjusting mortality in Florida
was the same as California even though
California enacted all of these policies
prolonged lockdowns school closures
vaccine mandates that uh that Florida
avoided for the most part and all of
those policies that had lots of
Downstream adverse consequences had no
public health benefit in California and
in fact my own Governor knew some in a
recent interview more or less admitted
that he was wrong on covet policy he
didn't say I was wrong he said we you
know we collectively we didn't know any
better but now you know hindsight is 20
20 and and whatever so he tried to soft
pedal it but he definitely walked back
his approach to covet maybe preparing
for a presidential run against DeSantis
and and not wanting to have that
conversation because it's hard to argue
with the numbers
at the end of the day
um and it's also clearly you know people
have people people are wise to this now
the City of Huntington Beach just up the
street from me in California uh recently
passed an ordinance uh basically uh
saying that we're not institutions
within our city cannot mandate masks or
vaccines so you're starting to see
pushback at the local level even when at
the state level uh we're not getting a
good response and all one other piece of
good news in this regard so DeSantis
sort of hinted at a law in California
that would threaten Physicians who
didn't follow the government's preferred
pandemic policies that was assembly Bill
which went into effect in January
January was in effect only for a few
weeks fortunately because I and four
other physicians in California filed a
lawsuit Hogue V Newsom is the name of
the suit
challenging that law on First Amendment
and 14th Amendment grounds that's a law
that would have empowered the medical
board to discipline any physician who
contradicted what the law called the
current scientific consensus on covid
which is ill-defined legal concept and
basically which had the chilling effect
that Physicians you know who didn't know
how to interpret the current scientific
consensus would just you know read from
a script prepared by the California
Department of of health so Physicians
having a gag order and becoming sort of
robots for State policy was going to be
the effect of that law fortunately we
got a preliminary injunction in that
lawsuit so the law has been adjoined uh
while our case is is going to trial and
just a couple of days ago
quietly in another bill as it was going
through committee the state legislature
basically inserted a portion that would
that would vitiate and remove assembly
Bill 2098 so the legislative
legislatures is quietly now going to sun
down this lie I think in anticipation
that they were going to lose our case
and not wanting
um not wanting to face that public
embarrassment of passing a law that was
in fact
unconstitutional and violated free
speech rights of Physicians and equal
protection rights of Physicians
yeah it's interesting how this stuff is
getting sort of quietly walked back in
some cases and yeah I covered that case
with you and you know I'm also a former
California resident so that's that's
where I was writing around California
we're in California I want to you
mentioned that interview with with uh
Gavin Newsom um I think it's worth just
playing a bit from that that interview
uh because I would like to get your
thoughts on the content uh of what he
was saying there
let's roll that
during covet
um you you were pretty strict with the
lockdowns here
and uh it was an interesting piece in
Harpers that sort of
was critical of your decisions
from this perspective
you found a way to allow the motion
picture industry and so and the in the
sort of the movie industry to get back
to work
but she didn't allow people to grieve
together at funerals or at churches and
that it sort of and that this may be why
there's such a polarized disconnect what
what you prioritize right this is this
anger between the populace and the elite
supposedly here you prioritize this
industry
but
you you know you were tougher on those
that just wanted to go worship what do
you say to that Chris I think there's a
lot of humility and we didn't know we
didn't know and it was hardly I uh it
was we collectively and I think all of
us and in terms of our Collective wisdom
we've evolved we didn't know we didn't
know we're experts in hindsight we're
all Geniuses but think about what we
probably ended up collectively
prioritizing your prioritizing industry
one specific one but then didn't
prioritize maybe once it whose maybe
values you didn't connect with I don't
think it's a binary there was iterations
within that theme there was there was
fits and starts there were Regional
Frameworks uh that had impacts more
broadly defined there were more industry
specific uh Frameworks all of us went
through a process I mean there was few
states that didn't go on aggressive
lockdowns including uh Florida's Rhonda
I understand that but it was more but
with but within the framework of the
open the door it's what industry got
yeah leniency in which yeah which one
that is all of it is legitimate in terms
of reflection always something you do
differently
we would have done everything
differently because we understood we
would understand Outdoors as an example
in nature you want to shut schools down
you had to try to figure out how to
maybe have outdoor classrooms no that's
not well now you're good I'm beings but
I think the nature of the spread early
on in understanding epidemiology that
spread understanding the spread in the
context of how it spread very
differently indoors than Outdoors is one
perfect example what a lot of us would
have done differently including again in
states red states that shut down their
beaches in the early part of the
pandemic
so is defense is kind of you know we
didn't know what we didn't know and we
all kind of you know would have done
things differently what do you think of
that Aaron I I think we did know and
there were people like me in the state
there were people like Jay bharacharya
at Stanford in the state there were many
of us who were speaking out who were
criticizing these policies from the very
beginning starting in 2020 continuing
through 2021
we had the epidemiological evidence to
understand the lockdowns which had never
previously been tested and were never
part of pandemic planning prior to 2020
and had been rejected by the public
health establishment uh would you all
ever try to get like an audience with
Newsome or any local officials if so
absolutely all of us were trying to get
a hearing and in fact we were silenced
we were suppressed in some cases we were
fired but even when we weren't fired
are universities vilified us
um people accused us of wanting to kill
grandma and so this whole it wasn't I it
was we no go back and look at
the stay-at-home order it was signed by
Gavin Newsom go back and look at his
press conference when he announced the
first lockdown in California it was very
much I am ordering us to do this and I
am taking responsibility for this so we
didn't know any better as nonsense many
of us did and we were silenced vilified
and in some cases lost our jobs
and I'm not responsible because all of
us and our thinking has evolved and it's
a big we is just a Dodge of
responsibility you're the executive
you're the one who declared a state of
emergency within California gained
additional extra Constitutional Powers
and utilize those powers in ways that
were enormously damaging the effects of
which will be felt for decades the
effects of school closures the effects
of lockdowns will be felt for decades
so I have no patience for this I have no
patience for this dodging of
responsibility I'm glad he admitted yeah
we would do everything differently now
um you know so you feel sort of
Vindicated as a Critic of lockdown
school closures and masks and vaccine
mandates but
um
but it's he's hardly admitting
responsibility he's hardly admitting
that he was wrong he you know he's he's
I don't know he's trying to deflect
responsibility onto some sort of
anonymous Collective blob and that
that's not how that's not how a leader
behaves a leader takes responsibility
for his or her own decisions I think
you're you're totally correct that
there's been a stunning amount of
pandemic revisionism which is what I
term it
um I've covered this a little bit for
reason.com specifically as it pertains
to teachers unions and Randy Weingarten
who our colleague Matt Welch covered
wonderfully
um as she was imposing some of these
absolute horrible restrictions and
lobbying for all kinds of disruptions to
schooling um on behalf of the teachers
unions which I think she's going to keep
the school open Liz yeah I I think it
laid bare the relationship between the
teachers unions and school policy in a
way that many people who aren't
Libertarians had never really
contemplated before but Randy Weingarten
exactly to your point Zach I mean she
she kept talking about how actually you
know she was fighting all along to keep
the schools open and it's like well wait
a second I recall at recent Magazine
having many a busy work day where I was
working and Matt Welch was working a
whole bunch of people were working to
cover articles specifically talking
about how Randy Weingarten was fighting
to keep the schools closed and so it's
going to take more than some sound bites
circulated all over Twitter to get me to
forget that and then I think about that
in terms of people who were much more
profoundly affected by that right like
it wasn't just you know libertarian
journalists were pissed off and busy
writing about it it's like children
missed out and in many cases they're not
reading at grade level and won't ever
read at grade level because of the
effect that Randy Weingarten had you
know the amount of alienation isolation
depression that some of these children
have seen it's it's just stunning to me
but the question that I have for you
because you've described with great
detail the sort of biomedical Security
State the biomedical surveillance state
that has descended on us or that at
least descended on us for some time you
term it the new abnormal in your view
did we are we in the new abnormal or did
we just narrowly avoid it no no we still
very much are and it's ready to move
forward into the next stages which I
describe in the book so even though a
lot of these specific policies have been
rolled out the whole infrastructure the
legal infrastructure that made this
possible the social conditioning that
made it possible is still in place just
waiting for the next real or
manufactured declared emergency in order
to ratchet things up again I believe the
next steps in the process which are
going to be rolled out under
non-emergent circumstances are the use
of digital IDs tied to biometric data so
the face scans that you see now at TSA
that are collecting data and monitoring
movements at that level and the that
being tied into a central bank digital
currency which will be the ultimate
method of social control through
financial control are I think the two
next steps and probably a thorough
discussion of those two things that
biometric based ID system and the
Central Bank digital currency system
which needs to be distinguished from
decentralized cryptocurrencies you know
that's that's probably a whole separate
interview that would you know take us
far afield today but I very much argue
so my book is not so much a
retrospective on covet I I really try to
frame it as this is a book about the
future yeah it's about what happened to
us over the last three years we have to
understand that to have an appreciation
of what's Happening Here
but what I argued basically is that in
March of 2020 what we got was just a
knock not just a novel untested method
of trying to control the spread of a
respiratory virus what we got was a new
paradigm of governance in that new
paradigm of governance has you know the
The Advocates of that have no intention
of slowing down simply because kovid has
lost all you know sort of plausibility
in the minds of the General Public
are there any policies that we could
Implement right now that would stall
this I mean the the future that you're
describing I mean Zach and I have
covered the cbdc issue pretty closely
especially because we're both huge
cryptocurrency Advocates and this is
something we cover so much at reason TV
we just produced um you know a pretty
long documentary uh from Miami's Bitcoin
conference trying to basically discern
are we in crypto winter what's the
future for cryptocurrency but cbdc's are
something that we've absolutely been
watching um with hackles raised or Worse
what in your mind how do we how do we
stall the the the implementation of all
of this what's the way that we can
oppose this if we don't use voice how do
we choose exit like what does this look
like in your view it's a really hard
question but what I've come to is people
need to be informed so that they can
voluntarily opt out you can opt out of
the face scan at the TSA
um you have to read the fine print on
their website right to see that but we
need to we need to collectively stand
back and say help no we're not going to
do this
um no I'm not gonna adopt the the cbdc
and we're not going to be trading with
it and this is not how things are going
to work
um I have some public policy proposals
in the last chapter of my book uh things
that could be done at the federal and
state level particularly to put checks
and balance systems of checks and
balances on the ability of the executive
to declare a state of emergency or to
renew and continue it indefinitely
without some sort of legislative or
judicial check on the system so I mean
if listeners are interested in some of
those specific proposals I'll refer them
to the last chapter of my book
um so there are some things that that
can be done I think at the policy level
but the more important thing right now
is people need to be aware of what is
happening they need to be most Americans
don't know what a cbdc is most Americans
don't know the difference between
a passport and a digitally based
identification system and why the latter
might actually be a threat to my Liberty
whereas the former is kind of more
acceptable so people need to be educated
on these things that's the main reason
that I wrote the book because I didn't I
didn't want to see a future
um like the one I I tagged on a little
epilogue at the end called Seattle 2030
which is imagining
um not new technologies or new methods
of control but things that are already
available that just have not yet been
rolled out on a wide scale but we're
seeing the beginnings of those rollouts
and basically I sort of try to paint a
picture of the kind of future that we're
going to be living in in in the not too
distant future you know it's not Seattle
2050 it's it's a few years from now if
we don't
um see where this train is headed and
take some specific steps to reject kind
of the worst aspects of it
yeah and I also just mentioned that
there was a recent ruling in this
Missouri V Biden case which you were
involved with and which I did a stream
with uh Jay bhattacharya a couple weeks
on which is the social media censorship
case and the court essentially argued a
rule that they coerced the platforms and
commandeered their processes for
censorship and upheld the core part of
the original injunction saying yeah stop
doing that white house so that's
possibly another method is to you know
get involved in you know if your rights
are being violated you know take it to
the courts and yep things can happen it
looks like you know you can you actually
can still get redress in this country so
that's a you know an optimistic
a bit of uh you know that's a
development that gives me some optimism
absolutely I want to I think that in the
meantime uh you know continuing to have
conversations like this one I know
probably to some viewers it seems like
we're rehashing problems
um that have disappeared from from their
minds but I think it's actually really
important that we try to have as many of
these discussions as possible where we
attempt to hold policy makers
accountable for the really heinous
things they did to us uh so thank you so
much for speaking with reason we really
appreciate it thanks Liz and Zach I